alors on va parler du foot et de ces
injures homophobes paris vous êtes des
[ __ ] ici c'est les hommes qui parlent
c'est en ces termes que l'ancien joueur
de manchester et ancien capitaine de
l'équipe de france patrice evra a
commenté la défaite du psg c'était 6 mai
dernier
plusieurs associations ont déposé
plainte aujourd'hui contre lui la
ministre des sports qui est outré par
les cris homophobes lancées récemment
par les supporters du psg contre l'om a
décidé aussi de s'emparer du sujet et
elle menace les clubs de sanctions on le
la présidente de la ligue de football
nathalie bois de la tour s'est exprimé
sur le sujet dans une interview au
parisien voici ce qu'elle dit on lui
demande si elle a été choquée par ces
chants homophobes et elle dit c'est le
flop clore le folklore du foot
j'assiste à plus de 50 matches par an ce
sont des propos qu'on entend
régulièrement ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils
sont acceptables mais ils font partie de
l'expression d'une ferveur populaire
qu'il faut prendre comme tel
martin club elle vient elle arrive
plutôt côté nathalie boisteaux président
de la ligue c'est du folklore ça a
toujours existé dans les stades vous pas
l'arrêter c'est que ça a toujours existé
dans les stades a effectivement il ya
même des supporters parisiens qui sur
twitter ont réagi aux propos de roxana
maracineanu en disant voyez on n'est pas
homophobe parce que on parle d' [ __ ]
les marseillais donc pour dire la blague
quand on va au stade et notamment lors
d'un match psg marseille où marseille
psg ce qu'on entend dans les tribunes
est assez effrayant là c'était encore un
petit peu plus le gaz lors de ce match
là parce que les supporters parisiens
avaient décidé de ne pas supporter leurs
propres joueurs à suite à l'élimination
à l'humiliation contre 1
contre manchester et donc du coup il
fallait bien chanter des trucs et donc
ils ont chanté un peu plus que
d'habitude contre marseille c'est vrai
que c'est effrayant
marseille marseille on t'encule souvent
des gens non mais t'as fait poli et bien
élevé bien sous tous rapports se
transforme
j'ai vu ça dans les stars des cadres des
chefs d'entreprise élégant comme comme
alex et moi c'était pas des choses je
trouve ça parce que finalement ça
travaille quelque chose qui sont des
instincts primaires alors est-ce que ses
instincts primaires doivent s'exprimer
publiquement comme ça dans un stade ou
dans un autre est-ce que vous m oui mais
est-ce que c'est l'excusé de la ferveur
populaire peut suffire est-ce que
effectivement cette foule parce que la
foule est toujours bête si je peux me
permettre
doit être maîtrisée est ce qu'on doit
interdire aussi les panneaux qui étaient
contre ceux du nord qui avait été
brandie on a interdit les les fumigènes
alors aussi les faits me gêne bon on a
réussi à maîtriser un arbre 58 cas c'est
non mais c'est passé pro ib il ya des
sanctions à l'étude au masque en fait
c'est presque joli mais c'est vrai que
c'est dangereux les insultes elles sont
quatre singes ou les assassins vrai
souci ça c'est pas tout à fait pareil
c'est ce que vaut de la tossée pas tout
à fait à la fin
on peut aussi aller chercher les
supporters au couvent des oiseaux au
collège de la légion d'honneur on n'aura
pas de problèmes éventuellement je suis
privé de football c'est sur les dents 1°
puritanisme tout ce qu'on va faire la
sexy formule là elles vont devenir des
formules de revendication de la liberté
à la rue que ce soit des formules
anodine un peu barbare un peu béotienne
gauloise
voilà qui font partie non pas du
folklore même de la sociologie on peut
s'en plaindre mais on est obligé
d'écouter d'aller au foot mais
maintenant réglementée et punir
ça va devenir des formules décrit
liberté voilà avant c'était liberté
égalité fraternité
maintenant ces gens qu'ils marseille
alors qu'est ce qui vous va pour
compléter ces se dit la secrétaire
d'état chargée de l'égalité femmes
hommes
marlène schiappa elle dit que ça les
stades de foot l'éducation nationale
tout ça finalement
il faut s'en préoccuper en l'écoutant
peut pas admettre ce type d'argumentaire
dans la mesure où ça c'est exactement ce
qu'on nous dit dans tous les milieux
pour faire exception à la lutte contre
l'homophobie et notre message justement
ces deux heures cela ne sert à rien de
faire de la prévention contre
l'homophobie dans les écoles comme on
fait avec jean michel blanc car si
derrière dans les stades vous avez une
banalisation des propos homophobes et
effectivement elle réagissait aux propos
de la présidente de la ligue sur le
folklore n'en sera rien mais il ya une
logique dans ce qu'elle dit a dit qu
commence dans les écoles aussi on
ne dit pas aux jeunes enfants ça ne se
dit pas quand ils voient que ça se fait
dans les stades de foot
écoutez nous avons connu une époque tous
où ces propos là c'était état d'esprit
là était encore plus probant l'école se
portait mieux la civilité se portait
mieux et le respect entre citoyens se
portait mieux
et depuis que ces gens là sont au
pouvoir c'était mieux avant c'était pas
vu avant c'était comme ça et depuis que
ces gens là donnent des leçons et a
introduit une police de la pensée
jamais on n'a eu dans ce pays autant de
crispation de haine ou de violence où la
police a fait même pas 10 ans surtout
d'ailleurs sur le sueur sur les opinions
politiques sur la il ya des choses qu'on
peut plus dire en se maintenant voilà on
te répond on a un doute sur l'europe on
devient quasiment un néonazi entre la
pyramide du louvre cette euphorie qu'on
avait le 17 mai et c'est l'état de la
france aujourd'hui je crois que des gens
comme un des échappés au dirt faire
attention aux consignes morales qui sont
en train de donner parce que les faits
totalement contre-productif et ce à quoi
on assiste est exactement le contraire
de ce qu'ils valent ce qui est vrai
c'est que dans le foot le foot un vrai
preuve avec l'homosexualité c'est à dire
qu'il ya très très peu de joueurs de
foot par exemple qui ont déclaré leur
homosexualité
rien quasiment un ou deux contrairement
à d'autres sports comme le rugby par
exemple où il y en a effectivement un
petit peu plus explique ça parce que il
ya effectivement un vrai souci et je
suis assez d'accord moi avec nathalie
baudoin tôt il ya un vrai un vrai enjeu
d'éducation
il ya un vrai enjeu d'éducation il y
entre l'éducation nationale et les
matchs de foot si les enfants sont bien
élevés dans les écoles on aura peut-être
moins de cris comme ça un an l'ancien ce
sont des sports via les brutaux de
confrontation bien sûr a donc tout ce
qui peut être alors l'homosexualité
sinon c'était ses mines et donc ces deux
mais c'est comme ça c'est la nature de
ce sport on va pas trop dur aujourd'hui
des codes moraux politiques et répressif
pour dire vous n'avez pas le droit de
penser ça vous a exprimé sa voix lors on
la gagne et c'est terminé c'est le
renard est née quand même on peut pas
dire n'importe quoi après tout mais est
ce que ce ministre là qu'ont beaucoup
plus de choses importantes à faire par
rapport aux autres panis qui ne s'en
souciait pas non vraiment je vous dis la
france est en train de devenir un pays
qui est invivable à cause de ce genre de
confrontation avant c'était encore plus
peu plus probant n'y avait pas de
problème donc qui pense un petit parce
qu'ils sont entretenus internautes
ils sont nombreux à réagir sur le sujet
faut-il sanctionner les clubs de foot
dont les supporters entonnent des chants
homophobes telle était la question quand
vous posez vous êtes oui vous êtes
parent dont 52% à dire que oui donc
c'est assez partagés mais c'est quand
même 52% pour dire que oui les clubs
leur tient il nous dit les clubs de foot
porte une part de responsabilité
accueillir dans les stades les
colporteurs de haine ils ont les moyens
pour agir mais peut-être faut-il du
clientélisme à des fins de remplissage
jeanne nous dit c'est justement où jane
pardon c'est justement cherchant de
l'homophobe partout et tout le temps que
l'homophobie se développe elle vous
rejoins plus tôt eriko nicolas les clubs
de football n'ont pas à être sanctionné
pour le comportement de certains
imbéciles
laetitia nous dit dans ce cas il
faudrait sanctionner tous les clubs car
leurs supporters ont tous des chants
homophobes ou à connotation homophobe il
n'y a pas que le psg et l'om est
terrible amar et maëlys ion permet tait
c'est que le foot fait un travail
fantastique au niveau de haut niveau au
niveau de l'éducation dans tous les
petits clubs
moi j'ai un gamin qui
on a joué en banlieue là bas on leur
apprend à faire les lacets on leur prend
leur c'est quasiment là que les gamins
freinent leurs seules douches de la
semaine c'est pas rien et finalement le
foot est résumée effectivement as écrit
dans les tribunes du psg je lui parle de
ça c'est vraiment la victoire 10 perdus
de la république c'est le football qui
les récupèrent qui remet de la
république la citoyenneté ou alors si à
ce genre de délit ça c'est beaucoup
moins grave que certains propos d'
irresponsables de certains responsables
politiques et la valeur du travail de
groupe du collectif dans le foot qui est
quelqu'un présente mais quand ça se dit
devant des officiels alors c'est vrai
c'est mais quand il ya effectivement un
jour de psg il ya tout un tas de gens
tout à fait respectables qui sont
l'armée qui ne peut pas dire oui c'est
bien c'est formidable a lésé des ptic a
continué à crier ça c'est normal bon
après tout est question d'en faire ce
qu'on en fait un enjeu politique central
d'une politique où est ce qu'on
considère que au fond c'est sans doute
plus de labo free condamnable que de la
vraie homophobie et est donc je pense
qu'il ya des mouvements qu'une évolution
de la société qui se fait sauf qu'à un
moment il voit là il faut pas par une
espèce d'homme et en espèces de 2 2
comment dire une charge de susciter des
contractions président au nom de la
liberté et c'est effectivement ça aussi
à converger puisque c'est interdit on va
le dire bon mais on sent bien que les
choses les esprits sont en train
d'évoluer
après le foot est un sport populaire et
donc c'est et c'est un moment
d'exaltation parce que quand une foule
réunie
c'est exaltant et donc quand une poule
populaire et exalté sordel ce qui a dans
la population on peut pas on va pas
changer le peuple il faut petit à petit
laissé les évolutions se faire les
accompagner mais pas aux forceps par le
tapant sur la tête des gens je ne me
sens pas
ni utile ni efficace
ils sont ils sont pas vous comment dire
s'ils sont pas vraiment homophobes en
fait tu sais c'est pas ça qu'on voyait
parmi douala
en france par exemple on est pour un
stand à cette chance-là par rapport à
l'italie c'est qu'il ya très très peu de
chants racistes
il n'y a pas de cris de singe comme on a
beaucoup en italie bon donc voilà on est
déjà à l'abri de ça c'est déjà pas mal
il ya encore du boulot c'est sûr qu'un
cran mais lourd sur les gens du nord
alcoolique on sent bien les pédophiles
bon on en avait plus torrides
oui bon ça fait partie
c'est là une imagerie c'est la
gauloiserie ce sont des formules qui
porte beaucoup moins préjudice à la
cohésion nationale que de parler de
gaulois réfractaires voilà ces deux
échelles de la saison à vie périco
encore quelques avis commentaires de nos
internautes
alors je reprends nicolas nous dit les
clubs de foot n'ont pas être sanctionné
pour le comportement de certains
imbéciles
johanne deschamps sont inacceptables et
mais que voulez vous faire un huit clos
s'interroge-t-il ok r34 latour existait
avant personne ne s'en offusque et cela
était oublié dès la sortie du stade et
pragma la tolérance et le respect sont
des attitudes individuelles vouloir les
imposer est une illusion nous dit il il
se terminera sur eux
enfin on terminera sur cette note merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre merci
particulièrement avoue sophie de ravinel
et martin couturier et plaisir ces
rendez vous demain pour un nouveau point
de vue merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
[Musique]